[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing severus snape draco malfoy
the killing of albus dumbledore
and one unbreakable vow the unbreakable
vow is a binding magical contract
that connects two parties the purpose is
simple
it is to bind a fellow which are wizard
to a promise the participants stand
opposite each other
and clasp each other's right hands while
a third party acts like a sort of
mediator or witness and places the tip
of their wand
onto the hands of the two participants
the mediator acts almost like a minister
and will begin to state conditions or
responsibilities related to the vow
after stating each condition of the vow
the participant who is to uphold said
responsibilities
must agree to them one by one in the
year 1996
during the opening chapters of the
half-blood prince narcissa malfoy asked
snape to make
one of these unbreakable vows and it is
at this time
that he vows to protect draco help him
with his task
and even finish it himself should draco
fail the conditions of this vow were to
protect malfoy from harm
while he attempted to perform the task
that voldemort had asked him to perform
kill albus dumbledore snape also agreed
to complete the task that malfoy was
assigned in the event that malfoy was
unable this is quite the responsibility
for snape to take on
particularly as if you're unable to
honor the promise that you've made with
the unbreakable vow
you will die death is the ultimate
consequence
and that is of course white is deemed
unbreakable you are stuck with what
you've promised until you either
act on said promise or die from what we
know there is no
other way of getting out of an
unbreakable vow but
one thing that i've always wondered is
why would snape willingly agree to enter
an unbreakable vow with narcissa
snape had been an effective double agent
for many years and both sides felt they
had an ally in snape
so what did he have to prove first of
all it's worth mentioning that bellatrix
didn't completely trust him
brothertrix was voldemort's most loyal
death eater and companion
and because she harboured feelings for
voldemort she was particularly
protective of him and his cause
this meant that snape's wish-washy
history left bellatrix unconvinced of
snape's motivations
when narcissa and bellatrix introduced
the idea of an unbreakable vow to snape
bellatrix was unconvinced that snape
would enter it willingly
she was trying to prove that snape
wasn't an ally to the death eaters and
this would be the ultimate test
would snape agree to kill albus
dumbledore so
the first reason that snape entered the
vow was just to disprove bellatrix's
allegations
the second reason that snape agreed to
enter the vow was that he was always
going to be the one to kill dumbledore
anyway though the task was assigned to
draco voldemort never actually expected
draco to be able to complete the task
this was his way of punishing lucius for
his failures
this meant that the task would
inevitably always fall on snape to
complete
voldemort knew that draco would fail in
addition to this
in order to appease dumbledore and
protect draco's soul snape agreed to
kill the hogwarts headmaster
himself this would simultaneously
complete the unbreakable vow that he had
entered
as well as protect young draco's soul so
there you have it
despite snape's impressive levels of
power and ability to act as an effective
double agent
he did ultimately need to enter this
unbreakable vow
both to prove his loyalty and to protect
draco
had dumbledore not already been ill then
the whole harry potter story would have
been remarkably different
and i'm sure that if that were the case
snape would have never agreed to commit
such an act all he agreed to do was kill
an old
dying wizard that was going to die
anyway to protect a young boy
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard howdy
you